hey what's going on everybody it's Bill
Burr it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast just checking in on you
just checking to see how your week's
going you know who's getting who doing
the next day half hour making some ad
read money and usually I just sit here
running my Yap
talk to myself but lately I've had a
whole bunch of guests and uh this guy
here is at the tip the top here the
Johnny Walker Blue all the boss
sketch comedy actors the one and only
Bruce McCullough who has a uh the return
of his uh Off-Broadway show Tales of
bravery and stupidity at the Soho
Playhouse in New York City October 14th
through the 29th
welcome Bruce McCullough Bill Burr one
of my friends and I can say comedy
Heroes it's so nice to be with you
I know I haven't seen you in forever yes
how great was that intro I mean I I
sound like a freaking professional there
you are a professional you are reading
for folks or listening to this and I
don't know there's not many
um he is reading from a teleprompter
it's it's kind of it's kind of sad and
you know what happens with old guys he's
got a little white stuff in the corner
of his mouth which I know I think yeah
it's a whisker okay did somebody tell
you this was going to be a video podcast
you could hide behind that windscreen
the entire time
you yeah no that's for your sound is
this video so I'll take this off this
that sounds like oh there there's the
money maker check check I just didn't
want you to know I'm wearing a wig as we
know I have uh
I have a William Shatner wig no you
don't you have no hair I yeah on this
podcast thank you on this podcast thank
you
dude I miss you man we did it years and
years ago we did uh we we worked on
something and I feel like I've seen you
twice since then yeah I'm so thrilled
you know the the new uh Kids in the Hall
movie and now you got your Broadway play
if I was back there I would definitely
go to the show
you would have an excuse to not have to
go to the show I get it
um but you should tell people what we
did because it's I remember when I saw
the actually the last time I saw you was
at Festival Supreme
um and then then you started phoning me
and going dude I'm TR I don't think you
use the word trigger because you're too
cool for that but you went I'm triggered
again I'm thinking about it because Bill
and I I helped write and direct I didn't
direct I helped write and produce a show
a pilot for Comedy Central I guess 10
years ago now if not more longer than
that it's like 12 years ago yeah with
him and Kevin Hart and it was it was
about their true friendship and my God
it was good and it's like if that one's
not gonna go and I I think it was a
money thing that you know probably not
bills people but probably I don't know
oh is that what it was I think that's
what it was because yeah he was just
blown up there remember when he used to
bring um a knapsack filled with money
that he'd get on the road which I'm sure
you've got a knapsack now with your own
I actually don't remember that I just
remembered that he would uh the reason
why the show was gonna work I felt was
because we were complete opposites
where I would just show up in my Prius
and he would show up in like a Hummer
with like you know 10 of his friends
hanging around the set and everything we
were complete opposites we were
basically playing
um
what exaggerated versions of ourselves
right and then we gradually we started
off happy and it was going to get darker
with our drinking issues and all of that
type of stuff but we never got that far
and you you were directing it and I
didn't direct it I produced it
um see I didn't I thought you were
directing that yeah I just remember you
came out one time and gave Direction and
made me laugh my ass up you did it like
you just were you were you were almost
you were imitating a director being an
[ __ ] and me and Evans just started
laughing and I just said to him I go
dude if this gets picked up how much fun
is this going to be oh yeah and what
happened it went right into the shedder
[ __ ] yeah um but a funny story from that
show it's not about you so you you won't
mind me telling it I remember because
you know Kevin Hart's great but
sometimes a little bit late just a
little tiny bit late
um he came really late to a writer
session that was at my house for some
reason I didn't know I had that amount
of power and he wrote on an index card I
Kevin Hart promised not because he had
been drinking uh to drink for 24 hours
and then he crossed it out and then he
crossed it out and went 23 hours
[Laughter]
which I thought was so funny but here we
are it's not like it came in but like
blasted or anything he was dude that guy
was like 27 years old making movies and
stuff so he had clubs to go to at night
I don't fault that yeah I think they
invented bottle service for him at that
time I'm not saying anymore it was I
think that I think that that's what it
was yeah but it was going to be uh it
was going to be a lot of fun and I think
the this business realized it so they
were like no we can't do that you know
what's funny right as I said it was
going to be a lot of fun and they took
it away you literally went like this
like you were imitating hanging yourself
I almost hung myself with my I don't
want to say it 300 scarf who am I
whatever 300 on a scarf yeah yeah
it's gone it's all right I've already
gifted it it was a Lifetime Achievement
Award for uh yeah that's what they give
in Canada they give you in theater here
they give you scarves because hey what
what part of Canada are you from are you
you Toronto what where are you oh God no
I'm from Alberta
um where I thought you're an animal oh
I'm an animal I was born in Edmonton I
actually you won't even oh it's a little
Cut Above a little cut the cattle's down
south the oilmen are up top I get it let
me show you the I guess you can't really
crowd there's a there's a scar from a
knife fight I had in the calgarian hotel
when I was 19 years old so I've I was
through the wars as a Young Man wait at
night like you had a knife too with this
guy pulled up no no a guy actually
caught me with a knife there was there
was a phase bail and you probably
remember this where guys would have
cowboy hats but they'd have little
feathers on the front of them like like
little I don't know what they were and I
I guess I'd it kind of had pissed me off
so I decided to take his little feather
off
you don't take Advanced feather off his
cowboy hat so that's that's what
happened and I was so hard no no Slow
Down slow down so you're in this bar yep
all five foot four yeah right well I I
Tower in at five six but correct five
six and you walk up to John Wayne
looking guy in Alberta which for those
Americans that's like the Texas
of of Canada as far as cattle oil you
know go [ __ ] yourself be a man let's get
a gun in that type of [ __ ] so you go in
there
coming up from a sketch class and decide
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
imitate I'm gonna improv with this guy
Yeah by taking his feather out of his
hat let's see and see what he does and
of course bill as you know I was wearing
nurse shoes at the time which is what I
often often work that was my go-to for
my drinking juice because they were so
comfortable and they were so Punk to me
what is your deal dude how did you grow
up in that place so freaking Macho and
like that is not your vibe at all so
what was so you you grew up out there
and everybody's [ __ ] punching cattle
and drilling oil and flattening the
mountains and you're you're doing what
reading Jack Kerouac and I was reading
Jack Kerouac
um I uh yeah well and listening to you
know it was probably not even yeah I
guess it was punk music by then because
I was 18 so that was you know 77. so um
yeah no I I grew up in reaction to the
place uh that I was I would dress I
would dress I'd wear pink shirts and
they would Chase men in trucks would
chase me down the street uh to beat me
up and scream you know what word they
screamed at me and um not hero they just
laughing at you I mean that's what they
would say what they called you you just
don't call somebody that that's that's I
guess that's correct this point you can
get you can literally get in trouble for
saying the slur that was said to you yes
that that I came out from under which is
why when I wrote running f word as we
like to call it now
um on this show it was that it was like
oh no uh gay men are heroes we are we're
heroes for folk Heroes for living
through what people in Alberta and
people in Toronto uh put them through
so what you just decided that you were
just gonna like
what gave you the strength that like how
how irritated were you by the uh I mean
it's a pretty testosterone place
Alberta like at what point was it just
for the sheer like uh you know it's like
a stand-up comedian you go up and you're
just like all right these people are
into this so I'm gonna make fun of this
this is their home team I'm gonna make
fun of their home team was it just
simply like that or had something else
happened what happened to you before the
pink shirt is what I want to know well
you know not to be too serious I come
from a pretty rotten childhood my dad
was a boozer and a Salesman he was good
at being a boozer and not good at being
a Salesman
um my mom left bill when I was seven
years old I wasn't allowed to have a
picture of her or talked to her I didn't
talk to her for two years
yeah and then my my stepmom Connie uh
who I I'd often say you're not my real
mom what's that Francis I I wish oh my
God now you've made me think of Connie
Francis and they were they were boozers
so I I you know and I had the house that
you couldn't bring people home home
because my dog would have Binky would
have attacked my dad my my mom might be
asleep on the stairs Connie from having
drunk her Hudson's Bay Rye since eight
in the morning and so I found basically
first it was Blue Oyster Cult punk music
and then it was punk music right and
then of course I fought
it's just I that's what amazes me that
like you you're just like the nicest
soft-spoken person you must be a terror
on set no you get to you get into Like a
Knife Fight and all of this stuff so
like
um did you get tired of getting your ass
kicked did you enjoy it did you fight
back oh no no I wasn't as good I and
there was a there's an actor that you
may know Callum Keith Rennie he was in
um what's that show he was in oh well
look him up uh he was we went to high
school together and he's become a quite
a good actor he was in California a few
things we would fight together he was a
good fighter I was good at just you know
bleeding quite honestly you were the
hype man yeah I was the right man but I
started going I had friends who had
moved out to Toronto and I started going
to Toronto where there was people like
me right and there was music and there
you know and the Buzzcocks played and
the damned played and I wanted to get to
Toronto as soon as possible and when our
show we had a show in Calgary that
became successful when I started doing
comedy I wanted to go to Toronto right
away and it wasn't for the comedy it was
for the music
that's amazing so where did you meet uh
well first of all how did you get from
Alberta
to Toronto did you did you have any
money to just fly out there did you get
in a piece of [ __ ] car and drive across
what are you Saskatchewan
yeah
I worked I worked uh loading trucks and
driving truck for Canada Dry
and what what you could do in the old
days was you go to your boss and you go
um can you put me on compensation for a
while because I want to leave town and
they'd say sure that was because that's
the old like the warehouse thing so I
kept getting these beautiful gold and
Canadian checks for two weeks then the
other thing is we had worked at a really
great Theater which uh did theater
Sports which you know is improv
competitive improv uh comedy
oh we started doing our show after the
theater Sports show and then we started
attracting an audience and by we you
talk about the guys who eventually
became Kids in the Hall or just your
friends a bunch of people but uh you
might know the name Mark McKinney was
the one guy yeah and so we started
selling they started we started selling
out this show at 11 at night
and then when we left town and nobody
got paid for theater Sports and they
still don't same with UCB
um they they said hey you guys have been
great
um you we've added up all the money that
you made and we're giving you they gave
me they gave us each four forty two
hundred dollars because we've been
working there a lot for two years
unheard of and it's like what and so we
had that money as well
so then you you flew oh we flew yeah
we're not driving no no and I think I I
think a plane ticket then would have
been 78 dollars one way
did anybody who ever beat you up you
ever see him in the crowd when you were
up there doing your thing at The Improv
Sports no but uh it's just a different
crowd no but a sideways story when I was
um when I was 15 I went to see kiss you
know the band KISS I've heard of them
yeah and they were so they didn't even
have a record out yet and I was it was
at a nurse's Cabaret you of Toronto or
sorry U of Calgary and I wait what is a
nurse's Cabaret they the nurses
department at school puts on a cabaret
and anybody can go so it's like four
bucks I thought it was a bar where just
nurses
I'd be there wouldn't you bill
um and I uh yeah to watch you lose a
Knife Fight to a nurse when you're
squaring shoes
hey those are my shoes give them back
you [ __ ]
um and uh I uh so Gene Simmons and we're
making fun of Kiss because they were the
silliest thing we've ever seen in our
life and they had a little kiss like
thing that was aluminum had like
aluminum foil on it like the big kiss
logo but it was like two feet tall sort
of like the spinal tap joke and we were
making fun of them and then we saw Gene
Simmons go get a blood pellet and go and
he split spit his blood all out and
stuff like that and we're going you're
such a joke you're such a stupid old man
a weird screaming at him he came down
with still playing his big bass and said
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you kid
and he did and then
um Gene Simmons beat the [ __ ] out of you
he didn't but he came back for his
revenge
um 30 years at least later but if this
was the 70s he was he was like a he was
like a Bill anybody who's a year older
than you oh it was old is old
um but he was too old for dress-up yeah
I think so
um and then like 35 years later
I look up and when I'm living in LA on
my uh at my long driveway and getting
out of a black SUV
is Gene Simmons and so it's like okay
he's here to beat the [ __ ] out of me it
just took him a long time no he wasn't
though he was I think he had a son or
something that was in a house near me or
something like that so that's that's not
that's like some Sicilian [ __ ] if you
came back that later I should have said
to him okay I know why you're here
but I didn't that's hilarious you were
like heckling though it's also amazing
that they had that little sign and they
and that everybody's laughing at it but
that was their dream and then just kept
getting bigger and we didn't know that
it was going to be they were going to be
so good and then I actually saw them a
couple years later
um with Cheap Trick and they were they
were pretty fantastic they were actually
a pretty uh you know I don't listen to
them now but they actually were pretty
good rock band
not bad for a bunch of old men you
finally gave it up yeah it feels like
the end of the episode but you just sort
of uncross your arms yeah or but maybe
uh and but yeah the people from the
network want you to do one of these
thumbs up
[Laughter]
um all right so then you go you get you
go to Toronto
all right and then you start you just
you went there for the music did you
play because I remember in like your
sketches and stuff there was a lot of a
lot of uh guitar playing and stuff would
come up a lot
um I remember you singing you know the
[ __ ] the bank I don't remember did you
ever play guitar [ __ ] the bank was one
of my favorite ones ever oh thank you um
I I play I play a little guitar I dabble
I have a Fender Mustang For You guitar
aficionados out there and I have
a beetle Bass the Paul McCartney Beetle
base that my dad played because he was
not just a drunk and a Salesman he was
also played bass in bands
oh he was a jack of all trades he was a
jack of all trades but mostly a booster
bill bill would I find with your dad is
he likes to pick jobs where it's easy to
get drunk
salesman basically
but I I always say that he he died 30
years sober his
um they threw him off a reservation in
Galician Alberta
um for being too drunk
and that was his low point and then he
didn't drink again
wow what a happy story no I just
thank you no you you look at you have
like movies there's like three movies in
all of this
so you wonder why I was such a little
punk right that makes sense
yeah but I I didn't know that you you
like you went out of your way to get
your ass kicked I mean I didn't even do
that I mean I I was a wise ass but when
you know
first time I got my ass kicked I was
like all right I'm gonna stick to the
jokes well when I but the truth is when
I because I thought I really thought
Society is [ __ ] all you people are
[ __ ] you know what I mean like ever
and I didn't know that there was people
like you out there or the people that I
you know I had said I had two friends or
maybe four friends two were in the
shadowy men from a shadowy planet which
was our band The Kids in the Hall band
and two other guys and that was it no
other friends and then everybody else
was stupid and that was you know the old
days when it's like if you weren't a uh
a jock and you didn't well I did some
drugs but you know you weren't a rich
kid what were you you were like us these
weirdos and so but there's and of course
those are the old days before the
internet bill
and Weirdos can't find each other right
as they can now which is the beautiful
thing about the internet well they
always found each other in cities you
just go to the art
wherever the hippies the art people were
that's what you would find
the fellow weirdos it is interesting I
always like that about cities and then
like people who are business-minded they
just look for the glass Towers they go
there or the steakhouses or something
and then Meatheads like me oh like
you've got a sports arena
you know if you have a bar with a bunch
of sports logo things and then you just
kind of you kind of find like your group
that's why I I feel like living in a
city in in you know as much as this
violence and crime and that type of [ __ ]
it's easier to find the group of weirdos
that that you that you uh that you
associate with but it is kind of funny
that like people that are into sports
aren't you know
that that just for some reason became
like this mainstream
like like that was somehow cool you
didn't play them you just were like like
if you go to a sports bar and you just
look at guys like all these animals it's
like these [ __ ] no one here could run
the block without doubling over wheezing
and they know everything about sports
somebody finally somebody comedian did a
great bit saying what's it like was
comparing Star Wars freaks to sports
fans and just made all of these
parallels of like knowing the names and
dressing up like you know you dress up
like the character you dress up like the
player and I was just sitting there
wanting to be like this isn't right and
I listened to it I was like yeah that's
kind of 100 right well it's it's also
and I I actually remarked this to one of
my friends the other day it was like
because there was a Jay's game it's like
why would you put the name of somebody
else on your back or would you get a
shirt that said Burr on the back like
you're gonna get a that's actually worse
yeah I would rather appear as as uh you
know a professional players boyfriend
that actually never make it in the
league and have my own name on the back
I did it one time uh when uh
I got to throw out the first pitch at
Boston but it made sense because they
put Burr in 22 like the year yeah and I
did it so when I'm an old man be like I
don't think
I heard that pitch bounced twice before
it got to home plate is that true dude
it bounced right up your [ __ ] pink
ass right to the place
like that you like to go to sports bar
and go I how can I cheer for people who
don't give a [ __ ] about who I am oh
here's the place
yeah I there's
you know what happened Sports kind of
like everything kind of got like
Overexposed and it used to just be like
you know it was like football it was on
once a week and they had a little half
hour show beforehand on this little
thing and then there was Jimmy the Greek
and he was giving you you know the odds
on who to bet on Brent Musburger Irv
cross and it was a Jackie Kennedy or
something like that Jane Kennedy and
that was the crew and you just watched
them and then you just watched the game
and the game was over and that was it
but there wasn't any all of this this
talk and like you know this [ __ ]
[ __ ] now with like you know getting
involved in players oh this guy's
getting a divorce or this guy got a DUI
and all of that stuff like I don't know
it was but if sports radio is what did
it I couldn't believe because I actually
became a huge ESPN too 24 hours of that
and then having ESPN one two three
University I mean I love it that says
there's all those games on it but like
it became like MTV where they were like
well we got to fill up all this time
we can't keep showing sports for
whatever they thought that reason and
then they just started sitting around
talking and they they [ __ ] argue and
just yell at each other and it's just
every time I hear them yelling it's just
like guys you're in your 40s who gives a
[ __ ] I I know I know and I I loved I
loved the call-in shows too because it's
like someone would call in and and like
go on against Garth org who's only
hitting 162 and he should be back to
Syracuse and I also love when the guy
guys of course only guys women are way
too smart for this aren't you women oh
there's no women listen to this
um they phone up and they go they go so
who's who's gonna win the game tonight
it's like who do you think's gonna win
the game tonight like dude we don't have
no idea who's gonna win the game I know
the Blue Jays or the Milwaukee Brewers
so why are you asking no they and then
they got the whole the fantasy things
the only reason why I like people that
play fantasy football and baseball is it
seems to be the best way now to know the
to know what's going on and know
people's stats and everything when I was
a thank you when I was a kid they had uh
you know like trading cards and I didn't
even realize that like instead of
looking at my multiplication tables I
would have been a wizard math if I
looked at those things as much as I I
looked at my football cards I knew
people's Heights I knew where they went
to college I knew their Hometown all of
this stuff what years they were all pro
if they went all pro last year because I
had all of that and somewhere along the
line trading cards because all of them
from the 50s and 60s and 40s were worth
so much money it became an adult Pursuit
and they pushed the kids out of it and
it was an early 2000s I started I wanted
to collect again because I didn't know
who the players were because I was doing
so much stand up and I went down to this
hobby shop or whatever if they still
have those and there was a bunch of and
it was down in New York via the
financial districts and there was these
guys like the the Wall Street guys were
down there and I saw this guy and he was
just throwing away cards he called them
common cards and those are basically
ones that weren't going to be worth any
money and it was like totally an
investment and I was like I was thinking
like why would you throw those car can I
have those cards I would love those
cards right and then I kind of looked
around the store and I was like oh my
God it's all like we were all like guys
in like our 30s
and I was like where are the kids like
they should be like down here
um I should look like some weirdo being
here and uh I guess I guess now it's
like fantasy football is kind of the way
to do it well and so you did you not
collect buy any cards then you you said
now well then what I hate it because I
just wanted to like get the collection
and look at it and get to know the
players as like a studying tool you know
and
because all of these these guys
these guys just Christopher walk in
there these guys all of a sudden had all
this money they could just buy a
complete set and they could buy numerous
sets so it was it was flooding the
market with cards and driving the price
down so what they did was they
deliberately made cards rare and hard to
get it's like the oil companies they
just stopped producing oil and then the
price of gas goes up and then whoever's
president gets [ __ ] blamed right so
they were doing that with cards and I
was just you know the whole thing was
just like ah man this isn't like this
isn't the fun of what it used to be you
go and you buy packs and like you only
need one more card and you're like [ __ ]
I just need one more card and then you
call up your book you know your school
one of your friends had doubles of it
and then you'd give them have to give
them like three cards that he needed it
was this whole we used to have like
Trading Card sessions
like me and my siblings and the kids in
the neighborhood we would just go into
somebody's house bring all your cards
and you just broke out what you had uh I
did that too oh man you got three Tony
door sets what do you want for that nah
man I love Tony doors you got to give me
more than that it was incredible and it
was like totally innocent and then by
2000 you know it was guys like me
[ __ ] the whole thing up by trying to
go in and buy a complete set yeah I
remember that too got it got it needed
got it needed need it like react yeah
yeah and then it became like don't write
on the checklist
I know oh right and somehow the
checklist became worth a lot of money
because that was like you know you could
tell what card it was
I don't know what does this have to do
with the fact that you're doing
Off-Broadway now let me let me ask you
this do you have to get to the theater
early so you can get into character I
know a lot of you actors do that stuff I
like to go as as early as 30 minutes
before the show
I like that I I'm not I'm not the person
who goes there for three hours I know
some actors real actors who go mama mama
mommy you walk into their dressing rooms
Mommy Mommy Mommy who are my mommy
um no
um I go
I go with my winning Spirit bill which
you've you've witnessed firsthand you've
worked with me and the people you're
round and about with everybody you know
you have a couple of [ __ ] pints I
don't have Pines but I do I I do go
gracefully on stage
um and lay it down you walk through a
makeup Mister before you go on there
just to kind of yeah and then I just say
girdle and then somebody you know from
Nassau comes and gives me a girdle
how long is the show
uh it's 75 minutes and lately I've been
uh I've been using you in my show
I do a thing I talk about like it's okay
if you don't get one of my jokes because
if you don't get one of my jokes it goes
over your head and to the end of the
universe and waits for me there which
which I sort of love as a just a weird
thing and then I go and I also I love
the low
and for some reason one night I said
Bill Burr can handle the low
and they loved it so every night every
night I go Bill Burr can't handle the
law and I think of you that's amazing
you know how cool that is
for me just growing up being a fan of
you you know because I'm so much younger
than you oh yeah you're a child no I'm
not gonna look at you yeah you look like
an old Superman I look like a ruined
astronaut
hmm
do you see it looked like you used to
save Gotham or whatever oh Gotham Batman
yeah uh no you do you have uh you have
that uh you're too you're too like nice
and sweet to have let like a life of
politics and just seeing the underbelly
um I feel like you're that guy that
people just go you know he really gets
life yeah because he understands it
until they get to know no they like me
how old is your son now he's got to be
like what 18. no he turns Otis turns 15
tomorrow my daughter turns 18 next week
yeah but he's he's getting he's funny I
know we can almost we can almost do it
like he's very funny
um up until I do a show called uh tall
boys uh the uh in in Canada which is a
great sketch show it's America available
in the US now but which went three
seasons or three seasons so far but
before that a lot of my shows only went
one season like I did a show with my
wife young drunk Punk and a few other
things and he called me Mr one season
like good morning Mr one season
I've been I already told this story in
the podcast but I'll tell it again for
you my daughter came up to me one day
and she goes she goes hey Dad
she goes I know what your real name is
I go oh yeah what's my real name she
kind of like pushed her face out she
goes it's Bill
and I go yeah I go how do you know that
she goes because I hear Mommy say that
to you like all right I go you want to
know my full legal name is I wonder what
it is and she goes what I go it's
William Frederick Burr she goes that's
ridiculous
go what and she just left I go why is it
ridiculous she goes it's a ridiculous
name and laughed and just walked into
the kitchen and she still won't get off
it she keeps but she I think it's a word
she learned at school because I asked
her I said um
she came in in the morning she goes dad
can I look at my tablet and I tablet and
I said no and she goes that's ridiculous
and it's just every time she says it I
burst out laughing so I think that she
she knows it's like a joke but I don't
think she knows how to like use the word
that's what I'm hoping or maybe I do
have a ridiculous name I don't know what
but she
it's pretty ridiculous bill I mean we
we're just kind of get it in my head
because she hasn't wavered I'm waiting
for her to be like no dad I was just
kidding she said to me the other day she
goes dad you're fat right and I go I go
you think I'm fat she goes no you're not
fat I go okay good she goes no you are
fat and she goes you need to go to the
gym and then she she starts hitting my
stomach and she's going like you need to
go to the gym we need to go to the gym
hi ho the dairy and she just started
cracking up laughing she's right too I
got a nice [ __ ] double cheese
sandwich here yeah Nia Center to to do
that too I know yeah you know Nina's
about ready to trade me in on a younger
model
yeah yeah well of course you know I
better change your hair the last time I
went to uh the doctor in La he said we
got to talk about your end of life
protocols and I said oh okay and he said
you have any and I said well
um when I die my wife Tracy who you met
many years ago
um she can't remarry for two weeks
and and he he laughed and then he wrote
it down which I think is fantastic so if
you give one last laugh yeah fortnite
guys I know I know you're circling so
you know I had a doctor recently go like
you know there's no good at your age
there's there's no good news from here
on out and it's just like why would you
say that it's like I know that but why
would you put me in that mindset that's
like being a coach like you know there's
no way we can win tonight
yeah yeah at least we could we could
keep it close we could give the people a
game or you can only play this sport
until you're 28 you know even if you're
really good that's why would a coach say
that to a kid
you know why because they grew up in
Alberta yeah
the whole problem with the whole
Northern Hemisphere all comes down to
Alberta and Texas because that's true
liberals man they're just there did you
ever think liberals would become such
[ __ ] psychos no I no I didn't I mean
Jesus Christ just so [ __ ] intolerant
and just happened I use I used to think
I was I don't know where I am now
all I know is that if I go to Texas uh
hey that was Joe Biden there let's go
[ __ ] rickety raggedy whatever they
say let's go Bucky or whatever they say
and then when I'm out here I'm like I'm
like [ __ ] counting the days until
Trump comes back
I'm kind of where you were when you were
young I think I'm going to start saying
Society yeah it's a society is no good I
well I like to go to a dinner party and
say especially when people don't know me
and go well Trump's got some good ideas
oh it's fantastic just to hear people
like that
fantastic I'm gonna use that I remember
we stayed at the Trump Hotel in Chicago
and uh there was people protesting
outside like the [ __ ] guy was in
there you know what I mean like he
actually is has any attachment to that
hotel other than loaning him he's a
brand he's basically a socialite
so the same way like Kim Kardashian
alone her name to to a brand you know
make some money he does that with the
hotels he's not [ __ ] in there these
dumbass Liberals are out there [ __ ]
screaming and yelling and we were going
in they were yelling at us I'm like I
didn't vote for the guy ah [ __ ] you
they're all screaming so then the rest
of the weekend we would get out of the
car we would just say positive [ __ ]
about Trump you know I'll tell you about
Donnie man I don't think he goes far
enough they'd be like dude
and then we went drinking I was still
drinking at the time we were behind
glass and and I'm not gonna say the
other comic but we knocked on the glass
and we were going four more years
foreign
and just laughing the whole time just
being like if they only knew that I I
voted for uh I voted for that crazy old
uh
the guy from Back to the Future there
who's the guy they they wouldn't let him
in every time and but don't you remember
like maybe in the 80s or 90 when you
thought the world's just gonna get
cooler and Bernie Sanders that's right
Bernie Sanders but the world's just
going to get more open it's going to
make discoveries it's and then all of a
sudden like what happened it's not we're
not more liberal some people like it's I
don't know what happened
no I think I think uh you know what I
think the internet happened
the internet happened and it turned it
into one giant Towny bar and then more
on liberals and more on conservatives
can now exchange ideas and that we've
kind of created this thing now where you
only listen to things that agree with
you and it makes you feel good and like
yeah you know like that like I find CNN
and fox other than uh like treasonous
they're hilarious to watch because they
just sit there doing this the whole time
like I'll tell you this country would be
great if everybody had on a blow tie and
then the other one everybody needs a red
tie it's like
I I don't I don't I don't know how many
times the government can just turn their
backs like what they did you know what
they did in New Orleans right what they
did in Mississippi
huh what they did in Alberta yeah I
didn't have another city I'm just saying
like how many [ __ ] times can they
just just show you that you don't
[ __ ] matter oh and listen we you know
not to get serious here we people in
America always think that Canada is
really great and we really also take
care of our first Nations people we have
the worst record there is so there is
millions of people up north have clean
drinking water and they why don't they
have drinking water like every time
anybody says anything all I can say is
but why don't they have clean drinking
water isn't that what everybody's been
saying for 40 years they need clean
drinking water you know what I think I
open with when I do Canada I go up here
in Canada I know you guys you guys think
you're the best white people
You're A Cut Above and I go there's
there was people here before you got
here where are they sent them up north
crying on a [ __ ] canoe
um and then I go into my act this is not
a way to make sure
oh nice yeah place that treated me and
Mike bertolina and Kenny fetter
very nicely in Phoenix Arizona it's
called he's wearing a fine ass cross
promoter shirt so please if you're in
the Phoenix region area uh please go in
all you have to do is show in New York
when I'm not there
I don't know you know I'm going to tell
a funny Bill Burr story I'd like how you
answered that like that would be a good
question
I don't know I should have checked with
you yeah it's the I should have
um we I remember we played Boston the
Kids in the Hall uh a little while ago I
think in our last tour and we were a
little theater small theater I think
it's like a 500 seater and we just we
did maybe four shows and then we thought
oh that's pretty good we went clean as
we like to call it for four shows and
then we looked and after us was Bill
Burr I think you did 16.
Oh I thought yeah yeah I did a run of
shows I'm from yeah I know but still
that's like you bringing your pink shirt
one-man show back to Alberta I mean how
many shoes are you doing it would be
endless there's still guys there who
want to beat me up so maybe they're
going to take another well you know what
uh John Mulaney came and and and uh
incinerated disintegrated my record so
he he has the record and I'll tell you
that fine young man he can have it yeah
yeah you can that was that was quite the
albatross around my neck
everybody talking about all the time
everybody on the streets you know guys
in sketch you know years later are you
still doing that edgy material I I heard
you were in that Chuckle Hut 13 shows am
I still doing edgy yeah I pushed I
pushed the envelope you know yeah it's
it's wow I like to try to make people
think
you know
oh my God I remember
yeah yeah I didn't know I haven't seen
that that's not bad yet no you you did
one piece it's like I always think it's
like how did he get away with this one
which I don't know if you've ever
thought that about my truck was like
where you talked about you can't talk to
kids because you don't think you're a
pedophile and then you go on to say that
you think some of their parents sort of
fatten up these kids so they won't be
attractive to pedophiles yeah it's like
how how do you get away with get the
head off the snake
that was my
oh he didn't no I just because you know
if you don't mean anything if you're not
being malicious
yeah I mean you should hear my new chunk
I'm doing on how not to get raped oh my
God and oh Jesus oh it's Jesus just why
would I yeah why why wouldn't you try to
help people that could that could
potentially happen too that's true could
happen to you too you know yeah I'm
helping everybody with my comedy see
most people just go out and they tell
jokes not me yeah I try to I try to go
like I have a PSA attached to every [ __ ]
joke that I do I'll do a [ __ ] joke
remember to get your colon checked
foreign
I think that's a scam by the way they
just keep lowering the age
first it was just like you know when
you're 103 you should probably have a
camera crew up your aesthetically got
dropped down to 70. it was like the
speed limit it just keeps going down and
down there for a while now it's down to
like 38. next year they're going to say
if you have an [ __ ] let us stick a
camera up now is this you're working on
are you like [ __ ] Scott Thompson
you're trying out your material on me
how dare you
how dare you compare to that that
horrible man
I've worked with them numerous times
geez just brow beating everyone in the
Green Room
I haven't seen him in forever yeah
well you're I I almost came to see you
when you're in Toronto but then I
realized it was at night
I think you're saying then I realized I
had better things to do no no I actually
suddenly came up I had some Neo punk
band I had to go see down at the [ __ ]
the attic or whatever you could see the
vile tones oh
yeah who was we were like into REM
uh yeah REM I'm trying I'm trying to get
your 80s playlist that's a little soft
for me how about John Cougar and the
Beaver Brown Band or whatever that
[ __ ] movie was called block science
stuff nothing is real you know with your
cowlick flipping around you never did a
cover of that yeah
no no on the dark side
and in a cruises oh Eddie and the
Cruisers yeah that's what it was it was
something John something in The Beaver
Brown Band
oh yeah oh he's John Cougar and then
John Cougar Mellencamp and then John
Mellencamp
yeah I knew him when he was John Cougar
I got his first record he's just John
Cougar oh yeah did you guys hang around
make fun of Gene Simmons I wish no dude
I think that that's what's missing from
a John Cougar Mellencamp uh Brody
Stephen Stevens show is he should have a
uh he should have a [ __ ] he should
have a blood pellet in his mouth when he
sinks little pink houses and then it's
going
yeah
I love that and and that's one of my
favorite drummers of all time Kenny
arenoff
played with him and I specifically went
to go see whatever he was going by then
John Mellencamp will say I specifically
went to go see him to see Kenny Aronoff
and Kenny did not disappoint I had lawn
seats at
um it was called Great Woods you know
John Cougar came out just [ __ ] I mean
that guy just says hit after hit after
hit and uh but I was just hold the whole
show all I looked at was Kenny air
enough bringing the hand up slamming it
down on the snare and I was like that is
a pro drummer and that's what I'm gonna
be
and then I started playing drums and it
didn't work out it's about as easy as it
looked it's not just doing it on your
lap at a party right bill you know I
thought I was grooving in the back of
the station wagon you know but then when
I actually sat down behind the kit
I had to put on my big boy pants I kind
of fell off the back of the stool that's
what happened
do you always do this to people what you
just sort of make them go through their
sad memories like sort of a little white
yeah kind of like a willy Lowman of
Comedy where uh
I I take up my sad samples and then
you'll you start telling show me your
sad samples you know sort of this and
then we all pick them up at the edge of
infinity
because we like saying that yeah I like
saying that and but those jokes are
waiting for me there don't you get that
bill that's that's about the circle of
life and I don't know why I've worked
with you I've taught you everything I
knew but why can't you see that
so what do you think when you what
happens when you die when you die do you
then go visit all your jokes that didn't
work in SoHo yeah yeah I mean I actually
did they all hug you and be like we were
funny we were waiting for you Bruce
we've always been here for you Bruce
since the beginning of time until the
end of time no I know that when I die
um a my wife remarries with it after two
weeks and but I also know that the
opiates in my brain just stopped working
and that's it oh I did leave my body to
science it's a joke I'm going to do for
you Bill
um and but they're going to shoot out of
a cannon apparently
oh that's awesome that's very that's a
very conservative thing to do I like
that yeah that's a red State thing to do
yeah and then send your liberal body to
a red state so they can shoot it over
the camera and I presume wild animals
would eat it still I guess
what was left yeah it's Gotta you gotta
be naked too because you don't want to
try to eat through your clothes
to the meth people well and of course
I'm gonna die naked that's just what I'm
gonna do Bill
oh I might I'm don't my body's gonna be
like a parts car where you just take a
carburetor here and a kidney over there
and then they're throwing me in the oven
and then that's it what if they go ah
don't want it and then the other guy
goes why and go I saw one of his shows
Once it wasn't so good
I feel like if you what if you die what
if like if I live to be you know [ __ ]
old as [ __ ] I mean who wants an 80 year
old guys
kidney
you got to be waiting for somebody to
like eat it in a car crash get a nice 23
year old pancreas that's tasty
you know it's like it's relative like
I'm you know for me now a 50 year old
that answers that's all relative but if
you're 90 are you wearing loafers and no
socks why would you say that's relative
annoys me I hate Canada now
you know I was gonna tour there I'm now
canceling it I think I think you took
all the money from all the people you
took all the money for all the shows
that you could do in Canada and now
you're back in the States just just
counting it making it right whatever I
was left with
that Wicked queen that runs your [ __ ]
country came by
you know just took all my little pieces
of gold
I think they were painted pink they were
pink and green
just like your politics
um
for you just tuning in Bill and Bruce
actually are friends they're just
playing
yeah dude I I haven't seen what
we live in the same city
bill I don't like you like that
no we've gone through a sadness we've
gone through a professional sadness we
would have just been I can hang out with
you now but we would just stare at each
other why do you think the show didn't
go
and then we let talk about something and
then we go so why do you think the show
didn't go and you know what that did
that gave us an opportunity to hang out
with our families
yes they're saying why didn't the show
go
but Dad I just want to play catch I
can't right now son
I'm still feeling bad about that failed
pilot I'm doing something called
processing what is that
I like to think they look back and be
like we had them
we had we had Bruce McCullough Kevin
Hart and balding Bill Burr
we had we had it all right in the palm
of our [ __ ] hand and we let it slip
through our fingers and open the door
for Netflix that's what I think I think
that whoever's left over there point
that person Viacom property
is saying no to Bruce McCullough
County to knapsack full of money is this
an ATC yes it is thank you for asking
all things comedy wonderful Network nice
that's uh for you who don't know that's
Bill Burr's company that encompasses uh
what they basically do is they find
young stand-ups they make them open for
Bill and they say no no it doesn't pay
it pays an experience in fact Bossier
should be paying us and it's like AIDS
and exposure
and then there's a table it's like no no
that's Bill's food you know what's
breaking my heart right now aside from
the fact that you just refuse to hang
out with me because I don't have enough
credits on my IMDb page is comedians now
young comedians are letting agents
take a percentage of their advertising
it's the most insane thing ever it's
like they can't do anything I'm just
gonna sit there and promise them oh
we're gonna get you all this [ __ ]
money and then they're not going to get
you the money and then they have their
[ __ ] legal foot in the door so for
the rest of time you're gonna have to
pay some [ __ ] agent and and they you
create the whole show you get your
listeners you [ __ ] do everything this
isn't like at an actor gig it's it just
yeah the way performers are like [ __ ]
institutionalized and they just keep
running back to the [ __ ] Penitentiary
just it drives me up the wall well and
you know it's actors are so horribly
treated they get paid so little you know
if you're if luck like I don't audition
for things but I usually hire people
it's like you get 2 000 you know
submissions for every role they treat
you poorly they make you wait on set
like it's terrible it's terrible so I
know being a comedian is hard going out
and I can't tell if you're making fun of
what I just said you know I I agree with
it and I think but here's what it is
Bill and I I try to teach you this the
first time we work together I'm just
trying to you know people just not be
[ __ ] paying people they don't need to
be paying that's all I'm saying I'm not
saying being an actor isn't a fun job
I'm just you know I don't know if it is
a fun job I think the money people right
now it's funner than being in the
[ __ ] edit room and having to put the
whole damn thing together I can tell you
that just doing your little [ __ ]
soliloquy and walking off
going down the street with Kevin Hart
and hanging out that's the [ __ ] way
to do this business
sitting there with the headphones on
going did we get it did we get it and
then [ __ ] a year later still sitting
there oh no trying to find the right
music for the guy when the guy [ __ ]
slips on the banana peel that's not
something that that's not no no it's the
freaky world of sound which is like all
these mostly there's there's women now
but mostly men just losing years of
their lives moving the sound of a door
up one frame oh is that too wet that
sound just said that sound like a wooden
door to you that sounds a little metal
could you play it a few more times and
confuse me you think that they're going
to figure that on the internet because
they have nothing better to do that that
was a metal door slamming instead of a
wooden door
um
all right
Bruce I mean I guess if this is the way
our friendship has to be now I have to
wait for you to do Off-Broadway to see
your beautiful face well maybe what I'll
do is play Gigantic Arenas like you
and you know but I can't I'm just
playing a little nice little theater
because I'm I'm actually an artist
because you're one of the people bill I
like to I like to see their faces when I
perform you never you know what it is
Bruce if that connection's not there
then what's all that money for man right
yeah I like it you're still punk rock
when you sit there in your little little
sweater my little sweater yeah whatever
scarf on my scarf I like it yeah
thanks were you protecting your
instrument I am you are all right I love
you Bruce you're the best and I would
love to hang out with you yes I will
find I know you're you're you're in the
Broadway club and it's not good for your
your brand to be seen with me but you
know we'll hang we'll hang way out in
like the Inland Empire so no no no I'll
get i'll get a second key to my room and
I'll just put it in your hand then you
come back to my hotel we'll have a drink
but you don't drink anymore so we'll
you'll have some just a couple of fellas
having a drink in a hotel room right
nothing untoward about that that robe
slips open that's the oops it's the win
you know you're just helping me out you
were trying to put it back that's all
that happened
and I don't fight you back because we're
friends
right he was stranger I said hey what
are you doing but it's proof so I know
that what you're doing is not sexual
yeah and a few maybe months or years
later you go oh hey that was a bit weird
it was a bit weird want to revisit it
just so we can confirm that it was weird
all right Bruce McCullough Tales of
bravery and stupidity now that we got
that whole background with you getting
into a knife fight wearing a pink shirt
I mean come on
uh October 14th through the 29th at the
Soho Playhouse live off Broadway show
the legendary the wonderful the
empathetic
Bruce McCullough everybody I love you
brother I hope to see you at some point
but when you're done with your run and
your adulation and your Tony
do they have an Off-Broadway Tony is it
called an Anthony
I don't know they probably do but I I
will hey everyone a little Anthony down
there and [ __ ] Soho gave me two
hope it makes you feel better I I'm
always on the the internet version of
whatever uh award showed us
they asked me if I wanted to present at
the Grammys and I was so [ __ ] excited
I thought I was on the Grammys and I
went I bought like a three thousand
dollar [ __ ] suit two thousand dollar
suit Tom Ford and I [ __ ] show up I'm
in the Valley on the internet
introducing the best Latino bands and
they didn't tell me how to pronounce
anybody's name and I mispronounced
everything and then all of these [ __ ]
white people you know who go to Taco
Tuesday got all [ __ ] upset for Latino
people
um well maybe you should ask that agent
that you give all that money to to ask
more questions next time you get a
booking you know I don't like being
confrontational
this is all just an act I I can just I'm
wearing slippers right now I know how
sweet how great I am I know yeah
all right well listen I pray for you in
the Ukraine
thank you sir and the Dolphins
and people that want to see you know
their face drawn on a bath one broom
door so they can be like yes I feel
identified now I can go [ __ ] in there
and have it go in the ocean
um good luck with you and and and all
the best for you and your act
it's like it's a person right your act
yeah I like kids give my best to your
act okay
all right you win you win Bruce
McCullough everybody thank you so much
and uh uh break a leg
uh on your wonderful run there from
October 14th through the 29th I will be
looking for a text message on October
30th saying Bill I'm returning and I
would love to spend Halloween with you
in a total heterosexual way all right
thank you Val all right that's it thank
you everybody thank you for listening
Bruce McCullough
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday October 13 2014 how's it
going how are you what's going on is
everything good with you is everything
go with you well yeah you look good yeah
I haven't seen you for a while
what else is going on oh yeah oh that's
good make nothing you know same old [ __ ]
my [ __ ] boss you know he's breaking
my balls well I'm not gonna bore you
with it dude what do you think about the
past today for [ __ ] real it's like
you know which team are they
um
I'm actually doing this out my living
room that's why I have the echo out here
um
you know like the old Capital Records
thing that they used to do right chances
are because
[Music]
um we got construction workers
downstairs so if you hear some [ __ ]
banging around or whatever that's just
them finishing it up finishing up the
goddamn job I always wonder what they
think when I'm up here [ __ ] singing
and screaming and saying [ __ ] you know
they probably think I'm yelling my wife
or bitching about the job they're doing
you know
maybe if they didn't have real jobs
they'd have time to listen to the
podcast like you like you are right now
how dare you in the middle of a [ __ ]
work week in the United States of
America you're just sitting here
listening to this [ __ ]
you know
aren't we slipping enough
or whatever the [ __ ] you are around the
world do you know this weekend I went
out and I did uh I did a show at the
Spotlight 29 Casino
with uh let there be talks uh Dean Del
Rey of the Let There Be Talk podcast and
uh Joe bartnick Rose Bowl Legend and
host of the puck off
um podcast and um are the peas popping I
gotta turn this [ __ ] volume down here
um anyways the um
we went out there we we had a great time
but we were on our way out there
and um
we're on the highway and I'm thinking
all right there's [ __ ]
three of us here we can use the uh the
carpool lane
and recently I've been getting these
tickets
for writing I don't know what going
through tolls and not paying and I'm
like where the hell was that
there's pictures of my car and [ __ ] and
I'm on the highway I had no idea what it
was and I was riding out with those guys
and they finally explained what it was
they said um
that a private group bought up a section
of the of the highway out here in Los
Angeles
and um
they own it and when you use it
you you got to pay them money you got to
give them toll money and all that type
of [ __ ]
and uh that was really scary to me
because if they were going to do that
why wouldn't the state just do it
why wouldn't they just say well [ __ ] it
we'll just do it and we'll collect that
money
God knows we could use it
right
but instead they sold it off to somebody
so what that says to me is this state is
so [ __ ] bankrupt they don't even have
time
to just
you know
just collect money on roads that they
already own they have to sell off like a
giant section of a highway
who's that group that owns the giant
section of the highway and how the [ __ ]
do I get involved and that's that that
business
I'll parachute right out of here I'll
never I'll do like [ __ ] a podcast
seven days a goddamn week I'll never go
on the road again won't tell any jokes
and you guys can just listen to me
slowly slip into madness
do you realize how [ __ ] that's one of
the greatest Investments of all time
I own a stripper like I own five miles
of a [ __ ] highway outside one of the
most populated cities ever with that
there's no public transportation for the
most part everybody's in a car
and every time they go up through that
[ __ ] thing ding ding ding ding
45 cents 45 cents 45 cents 45 cents and
I'm sitting here on my [ __ ] couch
just sitting here the bag of pretzels
and a [ __ ] Miller High Life
right just sitting here 45 cents 45
cents 45 cents 45 cents
it's the greatest [ __ ] thing ever oh
and I know what you're doing dude what
about the overhead what about it
it's already [ __ ] made
when do you have to pave it once every
four or five years if that I remember
back in the day the Mass Pike the whole
time I was there they they paved that
thing one time
I don't know what it is whatever man who
gives a how much could that [ __ ] well
[ __ ] that could cost a lot of money wait
a minute
I know if you do any sort of driveway
they always come in oh it's gonna be
about 20 grand
is it
all right more like three
um that could get expensive
I guess that could get expensive but
dude I'm telling you that is the move if
you can somehow
get in with the people that are going to
start buying up the [ __ ] roads over
here
and oh Jesus Christ
I would be such an obnoxious ass if I
was making money like that I'd start
wearing wife beaters and I'd have a
[ __ ] gold piece hanging around my
neck that just said 45 cents
[Music]
45 cents 45 cents 45 cents all right I'd
slowly just go [ __ ] nuts thinking
about it being like that guy pick up the
papers pick up the papers
hey Bill what do you want for lunch uh
gonna get a roast beef sandwich 45 cents
45 cents
yeah don't yeah he gives you a little
weird he's a little weird but don't
worry dude he's [ __ ] paying for the
whole lunch you know we uh he just kind
of repeats himself a little bit
um
so whoever did that uh good on you and
um
whoever
um has been in office out here in
California uh [ __ ] you you spineless
[ __ ]
all of you
how the [ __ ] do you go bankrupt as a
goddamn state
everybody going to work every day you
want to talk about 45 45 cents these
[ __ ] are getting money from
everybody
you're getting free money
free money
taxes free money
hey I'm gonna go buy a [ __ ] Chapo put
on my big stupid round head all right
that'll be eight dollars plus [ __ ]
you know whatever 80 cents tax
there you go you didn't have to do a
[ __ ] thing state government did you
all you had to do is sit around and wait
for me to go out and go buy a [ __ ]
hat
free money here you go here you go here
you go
coming in big pile of [ __ ] Loot and
then you blow all of it
how do you go bankrupt as a state
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
unbelievable I don't want to hear your
[ __ ] excuses well you know picture
that loose stretch you feel like my own
hotel I mean
um a highway I mean you got [ __ ] the
highway goes you know from San Diego all
the way up out go [ __ ] yourself you know
what's in there
around all those highways a zillion
[ __ ] people all giving you money
every time they go out to go by
themselves you know some condoms and a
pair of socks you're [ __ ] making
money you got plenty of goddamn money
but this is what happens
all right the [ __ ] public servants
the people who hold office they don't
make any money they make no [ __ ]
money I don't know what a senator makes
I know the president makes 400 Grand a
[ __ ] year okay so if your governor
of Los Angeles what are you taking down
a year what a hundred grand 100 Grand to
have everybody in the [ __ ] City say
that you're a piece of [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] everything up right you got to
have security so nobody comes up and
[ __ ] Shanks you every time you go out
to go get a club sandwich
and not to mention it costs millions and
millions and millions of dollars to
campaign to get that [ __ ] job and in
the end all you get is a hundred grand
those guys they are set up to be bribed
I this is 100 believe this [ __ ] so
basically
you're going for a job that's going to
get you a hundred grand and you need
millions and millions of dollars to
[ __ ] get the thing so now you got to
get in bed with all these fat cats that
can [ __ ] buy up the goddamn highways
and that's what they do right
tell you what I'll Finance your foot
listen to me hey [ __ ] shut up
I'm gonna [ __ ]
what do you need money how much money
you need for this time eight seven nine
million what the [ __ ] do you need all
right hey 20 40 68 [ __ ] keep it all
right but
all right I or You in return you got to
give me
you got to give me 10 miles of the
[ __ ] 10.
or the five
let me get the five all the [ __ ]
hippies driving up to San Francisco let
me get 10 10 miles of that and I'm not
finished
let me get 10 miles of that
and uh let's make uh let's make it a
no-fly zone
over uh Disneyland whatever the [ __ ]
they want right
then that's what happens or whatever you
know what I'm gonna do this job I'm
going to repay I'm gonna be the guy who
[ __ ] repaves it I'm gonna donate two
million dollars to your [ __ ] campaign
to get this job that makes 100 Grand a
[ __ ] year
and maybe eventually get to the White
House so you get that Marilyn Monroe
side [ __ ] and then you get to go on the
[ __ ] golden parachute million dollar
a speech [ __ ] gig after you retire
and in the meantime I want the contract
to do this job for the state and I'm
going to charge you [ __ ] nine million
dollars for a hammer that's the old
[ __ ]
urban legend goes and that's how you go
[ __ ] bankrupt there you go
[Music]
any morning podcast as I mentioned um
that was a good 10 minutes of horseshit
[ __ ] spelled w is it horseshit like you
[ __ ] who or is it horseshit
and you just say so fast it's [ __ ]
you know what I'm gonna google that
right now let me see let me look up
horseshit
h-o-r-e-s-h-i-t you know if you curse as
much as I do you should really find
dictionary horseshit
it is a word shithore [ __ ] [ __ ]
whorefish [ __ ] face look at this
she used to horse [ __ ]
not embarrassed at all she's used to
horseshit or is it horseshit
I think we can all agree it's definitely
[ __ ] right girls
on IRC this is Urban Dictionary girls on
IRC which I don't know what that is
who are desperate for attention and will
latch onto any scum they find
also gets naked on cam for attention and
sends out pics of themselves committing
odd Acts
to their anus
Jesus Christ what's funny about the
[ __ ] Urban Dictionary just like the
web stuff
in the dictionary you got to look up
like another five [ __ ] words
odd
I remember ODB that was old dirty
bastard old dirty dick what
um sends out picks themselves committing
to odd acts I feel like the white cop on
Stanford's son right now what's going
off
um
odd
what the [ __ ] would that be
other dudes dicks
out pictures of themselves committing
other dudes dicks acts and that doesn't
make sense
not Jesus Christ now I gotta look this
up see what happens this is how you lose
the whole [ __ ] day this is why
nothing is getting done in this country
because you [ __ ] go to the Urban
Dictionary as a white guy like me
Oppositional Defiant Disorder
now what the f oh Jesus you know what I
don't even give a [ __ ] anymore
oh my god he has odd
force him Force drug him it can't have
anything to do with ridiculous success
of punishment as restrictions
operational defiant disorder
surprisingly it's real a fake disorder
pulled out of their asses
of a small Collective of psychiatrists
working for pharmaceutical companies in
order to maximize Revenue
of course there's no uh you know what's
funny I don't even know what I'm talking
about anymore all right I'll chalk that
up to be white as [ __ ]
um
anyways
plowing ahead here
um
[Music]
do you guys watch any of the football
this week of course you did of course
you did you had nothing better to do
just like me you like how I'm doing that
I'm dragging you into my own [ __ ]
world
um I actually didn't watch too much of
it I was running around like a maniac
um I did watch my Patriots
um
don't let the final score fool you was a
lot closer than you thought it was I
mean we were only up by eight
we're four minutes to go
against the Buffalo Bills
this is why I can't I can't buy into the
Patriots team yet people are like oh
yeah they beat the Bengals
you know
we had a close game against the Raiders
they're Raiders right they've stuck
I I've stunk they've stunk since they
were they were in La who's kidding who
no that's not true they had the uh the
snow cone game where they lost to us
because of an obscure rule I love how
Raider fans think that that game was
[ __ ] it wasn't [ __ ] the rule was
[ __ ]
but the call was not [ __ ] it was
right on the money what was [ __ ] was
the roughing the passer call against
sugar bear Hamilton that got the radius
into Super Bowl 11.
all right so quit your crying go put on
your makeup and your stupid [ __ ]
costume and go sit in the end zone and
think that you're intimidating somebody
oh you might intimidate me I'm in The
Stance no one gives a [ __ ] about me but
you're not going to intimidate a
professional football player with your
goddamn outfit
when I look at when I when I bite into a
York Peppermint Patty when I look into
the [ __ ] end zone
of the goddamn rages right and I see the
sadness that that fan base has become
I'll never get over because I [ __ ]
love the Raiders that's one of the most
that is arguably the best logo
in all the National Football the
everybody who the [ __ ] hasn't tried to
rip off
putting some sort of black into their
uniform to try to be more intimidating
or at least the amount of people who
have right
Atlanta Falcons the old Houston Oilers
didn't they do that oh Jerry Glanville
just went and got a black jacket
that [ __ ] idiot he shouldn't have
been a head coach he should have been on
like Falcon Crest
um or the Dukes of Hazards or something
like that
who else everybody for a while I can't
remember everybody would always switch
their uniforms to Black because they
want to be more [ __ ] intimidating
when they're 80s were smart enough from
day one
right the silver and black and they had
a [ __ ] pirate
on the side of the helmet they've never
had to change it look at look at every
[ __ ] team out there had to change it
had to eventually was like all right you
know what the [ __ ] are we thinking in
1960 or 19 whatever everybody has [ __ ]
with their goddamn low logo except for
their 80s they never had to they got it
right right out of the gate like that
fat [ __ ] they pull out of the stands to
try to hit a half court [ __ ] shot
right so we can go out and go win a
[ __ ] Dodge opal or whatever the [ __ ]
they're giving away oh my God I can't
even afford the insurance right some
meaty fat tit [ __ ] [ __ ] goes out
there nothing but net that's what they
did back in 1960.
and sure there's other teams that
couldn't admit that they [ __ ] up
like the Dolphins
when you really think about the dolphins
that is probably the worst [ __ ] name
considering the sharks was still on that
was still available
they could have been the sharks they
could have some badass [ __ ] logo I
mean if you're gonna go with some sort
of porpoise type looking fish
right
what do they do they they pick the
Dolphins
why don't you just call yourselves the
[ __ ] right that logo should have had
a [ __ ] beach ball right on the end of
its goddamn nose
so anyways they s but they stick with
this thing for so goddamn long they win
two Super Bowls they go undefeated back
when you played like [ __ ] 12 games
and nobody gave a [ __ ] there was no
pressure whatsoever
right
they went to another two Super Bowls I
think yeah in the 80s one with Don
strzok and one with uh Dan Marino
and after a while you just kind of you
just kind of forgot that they were the
Dolphins and they had that silly ass
logo and it never
dawned on me again how stupid that
[ __ ] name and logo was until they
changed it
they changed it what last year
I think they changed it last year I
think I already made fun of the logo but
whenever I look at that logo that logo
to me looks like it's the logo of a
corporation that just had a massive
[ __ ] oil spill in the gulf and now
they're trying to pretend like they give
a [ __ ] about the environment so they
switch up
their logo you know
kind of like BP did
they put like that [ __ ] looks like
corn and grass is the color of their
logo like oh wow they care about us they
care about the trees
um they don't
um all right how far into this [ __ ]
podcast are we at this point
18 minutes another [ __ ] nine minutes
of [ __ ] there we go oh it's time for
a little bit of advertising all right
here we go everybody meundies me undies
me undies cupping my [ __ ] balls
my dick and balls that's all
not writing up my [ __ ] crack all
right it's unbelievable how putting on a
great pair of underwear changes your
entire outlook for the day that is not a
joke feeling that velvety smooth
material
up against your privates you know that
feeling of putting on that ratty old
saggy underwear oh my god dude we got it
I want you to know the feeling of
wearing great fitting great looking
underwear like Jim [ __ ] Palmer
you need to know more about meundies.com
meundies has the most comfortable
underwear you have ever tried on
they fit perfectly
they don't ride up on you of course they
fit perfectly there's not that much
material it's like you're making pants
what do you got to measure the inseam
with somebody's [ __ ] taint
um actually I've heard these are great
by the way um they fit perfectly they
don't ride up on you and they literally
pull moisture away from your scross
from your skin
so you're cool all day long
that doesn't make any sense
you sweat to cool yourself off now
you're pulling the moisture away
why don't you just come out and say at
me on these you're not gonna have sweaty
balls as long as you wear our stuff
me undies me undies no more sweaty balls
but but here's the thing they also make
you look great
what does that mean
do they frame your package
like a strike that hits the [ __ ]
Corner
um go to meundies.com and check out
pictures of all different styles of
underwear and for girls check out those
hot looking boy shorts
men and women high quality materials for
your high quality
materials oh I get it uh if you know
what I mean sorry I totally blew that
high quality materials for your high
quality materials if you know what I
mean
the price glad you asked a fraction of
what typically high-end designers charge
who the hell buys designer underwear
it's like having designer [ __ ] piping
in your walls
oh my God is that your initials on the
pipes I can't see here I'll help you out
go to meundies.com
get 20 off your first order 20 off your
order when you go to meundies.com and
right now you'll even get shipping
you'll get free shipping in the United
States and Canada so basically if you
live in North America
north of Mexico
in Central America she's a hammering
down there
north of all Central America
for some reason
you know
Central America and they're not focusing
on you think that that's where the most
sweaty balls are going to be at right
isn't this a sketch on [ __ ] SNL my
Chevy balls
um basically the United States and
Canada
the highest concentration of white
people with sweaty balls are in the
North American area and for years we
have walked around
with a devastating
condition of hot balls well thank god
since me undies came on the list
came on the scene all right you get it
people all right DraftKings everyone
list listeners are winning huge cash
prize every let me start over again
draftking oh
what in God's name could they be doing
down there I think they're putting in
the [ __ ] floors all right DraftKings
everyone listening listeners are winning
huge cash prizes every week at
draftkings.com America's favorite
one-week fantasy football site one week
fantasy means no season long commitments
play whenever you want got an injured
player not a problem at DraftKings where
it's like a new season every week so
you're never stuck with the same players
pick your team in minutes and you could
be on your way to winning instant cash
last year one player turned 11 bucks
into four grand and another one a
hundred grand for his first time ever
playing and another player won a million
bucks in one day just playing fantasy
football
hurry and get a free and get free entry
into the 100 000 fantasy football
contest this weekend where first place
takes home ten thousand dollars call to
action this one's supposed to get really
intense head over to draftkings.com now
and enter the promo code defense to play
for free draft
bigger events big
big millionaires at the defense for
every entry now at draftkings.com
draftkings.com that once again is
draftkings.com because of that man right
there a retinal James Simpson
um
all right there you go I think that's
[ __ ] hilarious there's a couple
things that are really
when you watch like an NFL football game
did you have you like watched the
advertising
like how much of a [ __ ] like
psycho loser they think you are
first of all they're running that
[ __ ] that ad every 10 minutes don't
hit women
no more
no more she slipped on the coffee cake
no more
I actually I was stretching and
accidentally pushed her down the stairs
no more
no more uh we were playing football and
she tried to block a kick she tried to
block the the punt
dude she was roughing me she's not
supposed to run into the kick I ain't
fall up my fault my
[ __ ] sneaker hit her face you know
um so they got that going on so
basically white they think we're wife
beaters
all right every five seconds she got
some sort of you know your dick doesn't
get hard and you're going bald
you're a balding limp dick wife beater
right and then they run the [ __ ]
DraftKings
you're a degenerate Gambler you're a
degenerate gambling bald limp dick
[ __ ] wife beater
nothing positive
they're [ __ ] no more commercial
[ __ ] annoys me because I feel like
they're yelling at me and I don't hit
women so why don't you [ __ ] tone it
down a little bit
okay
I actually tweeted this out you know
when you watch a WNBA game do they start
yelling at all the broads watching that
[ __ ]
you know no more marrying a guy just
because he's got money
but you don't love them
no more I'm used to a certain lifestyle
do they do that [ __ ] of course they
don't it'd be considered find out
something [ __ ] wrong
I don't know more campaign and
everybody's dressed all in black you
know they think on the cover of the
[ __ ] Beatles album
you know my favorite part of all of it
can somebody please explain to me how
they didn't do it like didn't do any
sort of background check on iced tea and
he got in that [ __ ] commercial
according to his albums wasn't he a pimp
at some point
I don't know I don't know much about the
pimpit game but as far as I know you
know if you started off as a pimp you
probably made your first million
smacking [ __ ] every couple of seconds
huh [ __ ] where's my money
[Music]
I love iced tea every time you [ __ ]
see that guy he's always talking about
the street
you know yo I could make I could make
five grand at 20 minutes
every [ __ ] time
and I don't give a [ __ ] what you bring
up iced tea is gonna bring up the street
and how much money he could make how
quickly
hey ice tea isn't it a beautiful day out
here I'll tell you what's beautiful when
I was out on the street I could make
five grand in 20 minutes
yeah I was just kind of talking about
the weather
every [ __ ] one of those VH1 things
from 10 years ago All Those Behind the
musics anything blah blah blah I don't
give a [ __ ] what they were talking about
iced tea eventually came on and told you
that he could make five grand in 20
minutes when I was out on the street
the pimping game see the pimping game oh
shut up about the [ __ ] pimping game
you know that the whole thing is
romanticized see when you get some
runaway to go out and sell her [ __ ] for
money there's an art to it is it you
[ __ ] creep you know what's funny I
don't even know was he was he a pimp
all those albums [ __ ] ran together
they all came out they were so [ __ ]
overwhelming when I first heard them you
know I'm sitting here a little white boy
living in the cul-de-sac and all of a
sudden Eazy-E and all these guys came
out I couldn't keep up with who was
getting shot who was getting smacked so
I might be wrong on that one but am I
the only one who was like wait a minute
that's that guy who can make five grand
in 20 minutes smacking [ __ ] out there
and selling crack right
no more
ah Jesus I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about anyways let's get down to
the football this week so I watched the
Patriots obviously it was a big victory
on the AFC East the weak Olympic [ __ ]
AFC East
Jesus Christ man what has happened to
the [ __ ] Jets
and the Jets they're [ __ ] falling off
the face of the earth now what a lot of
people would think that the Patriots are
going to have an easy Victory cut this
Thursday a Thursday night football and
I'm here to tell you that probably won't
happen
I'm actually not buying it
because uh
oh Jets always play as tough
all right I'm gonna sell you a bad game
the Patriots versus the Jets Thursday
Night Football
all right you know I'll tell you the
Jets yeah they got their backs up
against the wall you know I wouldn't
count out this Rex writing they're still
brought to his system I know they've
lost nine games in a [ __ ] row
um
they're actually in a uh it was actually
a rough uh
a rough week for uh
New York football huh Giants got this
[ __ ] kicked out the Eagles really that
[ __ ] good
I mean I just I don't know I just kept
thinking you know all right the Giants
are going to make some sort of halftime
adjustment at some point right
it was brutal though huh
Crews got [ __ ] that brutal injury oh
look at this [ __ ] here I'm on a New York
Post hard to believe radio hosts excuse
for mocking Cruz injury a Philadelphia
radio host added insult to injury Sunday
night mocking Giant star receivers
Victor Cruz after he injured his right
knee in the second half loss how is it
hard to believe that anybody in Philly
does anything other than I guess if they
act like human beings then it's actually
hard to believe
Crews who had just dropped a fourth down
pass in the end zone tore his patellar
tendon ow on the play and immediately
grabbed his knee
Mike missanelli hey Mike [ __ ]
missinelli a radio host for 97.5 The
Fanatic made fun of Cruz's salsa dancing
as he writhed in pain I gotta admit
that's kind of funny hey giant fan
Rick's Victor Cruz is over dance to that
oh God okay wait a minute
I thought he was going to be like ow I
think he's gonna do something like that
that would have made me laugh as Cruz
was carted off in tears the fans in
attendance at Lincoln Financial Field
gave him a sincere Round of Applause oh
look at that see look at me I'm saying
all Eagle fans are bad I guess they're
not and missing a soon backtrack detail
deleting the tweet and replacing it with
multiple apologies
ah somebody was home drunk watching the
game hey giant Fizz Cruz is done
dance to that tweet
just sitting there laughing that's a
good one that'll get me some more
listeners and all of a sudden all the
hate starts coming in he starts sweating
all over the place except down on his
balls because he's wearing me undies me
undies no more sweaty balls
um
this is what he wrote he said I
apologize for the cruise tweet I didn't
see that he got hurt on the play was
outside the stadium and saw he dropped
it walking to my car you lying sack of
[ __ ] he goes I just saw on big screen
outside stating that he dropped the pass
didn't see that he got hurt on my on the
play my bad I would never have tweeted
that had I known he got injured please
know that now what
you're foolish dude Victor Cruz is over
right there that means you know he got
hurt
oh Jesus you know what this guy doesn't
need me undies be undies no more sweaty
balls because he doesn't have any balls
just say listen I was at the game I got
[ __ ] hammocked
and I made a joke that a lot of people
made I was actually in a cigar bar last
night watching the game and somebody
made that joke
um and people laughing like oh you know
but you know what the [ __ ] you're gonna
sit there boo every time you score a
touchdown
the joke's just laying there waiting for
somebody to say it
um
he combine that with some alcohol and he
combined that he's in Philly so he's got
to be at least three quarters of a
[ __ ] animal animal
voice is cracking
um
actually had a great time I went to this
awesome cigar bar last night and I
watched the uh
Giants Eagles game even though the game
was just [ __ ] it just was so
one-sided it's just a wall why why the
why ass kicking
um and we actually was sitting there and
um
Jesus Christ they're hammering right
underneath me
this is what has been people for the
last [ __ ] six months
I know what you're thinking six months
Jesus Bill what are they rebuilding the
whole downstairs yes yes they are
and now they're going to put in the
hardwood floors and then they found out
the floor wasn't level
and the guy [ __ ] goes hey Bill uh was
this out downstairs area ever outside
yeah it was
let me guess let me guess
it used to be some sort of half-assed
porch so they had it raked you know
they'd have a nice [ __ ] whatever 15
degree angle so the rain water would
roll off it now it's inside
whatever
when you're downstairs in my house you
just feel like you're on a boat that's
making a left turn or a right turn
depending on which way you walk and I
don't give a [ __ ] no it's not that bad I
never even noticed to be honest with you
but um
you know he went down there with the
level and that little ball just kind of
rolled a little bit to the side I don't
give a [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] you know I give a
[ __ ] but I just I don't have any more
money I don't have any more money to
throw at that okay I'm cutting you off
all right son it's over you got to get
out in the world and get a [ __ ] job
um
so anyways uh went out there with a
couple of buddies
smoked a couple of cigars and uh
was watching the game it just was just a
wire to wire [ __ ] beat down and um
I don't know I was disappointed in the
game I was impressed obviously with
Philly I know the Giants started off
rough they've been playing better
uh but still I didn't think it was going
to go like that and I've actually I've
always loved the NFC East it's always
just been uh it's always been great
football really great rivalries and that
type of thing it sucked that the the
Redskins have not been a factor for so
long because those Cowboy Redskins games
um were always great when I was growing
up
um but I guess there's always one team
that's going to suck in your division
somebody's got to come and last it's
just been them for a while
um for whatever reason
um
all right is that all I had to say in
football I I honestly didn't watch a lot
um I would have to think that they're
[ __ ] calling for Rex Ryan's head at
this point are they still sticking with
them
are they still sticking with the guy I'm
actually going to be upset if he gets
fired because I love watching him lose
you know
and if they fire him I I don't get to do
that anymore
all right here we go and
what do we got here spit it out Bill New
York Post sports all right
Kevin Durant hurt his foot the Yankees
A-Rod Mysteries are much deeper than you
think ah A-Rod my favorite Yankee of all
time
the 200 million dollar albatross
um let's see Gronk Swagger returning to
the Patriots
uh I see I guess he made a quote they
should get laid
what the [ __ ]
um
Jets pick six ending a gambling miracle
for Broncos backers
yeah I don't see them getting saying get
rid of Rex Ryan yet well it's very
surprising for the New York Post they
usually got the sky has fallen after two
[ __ ] days
um all right I gotta look at this story
here sorry guys I'm just you just listen
to me read the newspaper this week Gronk
Swagger to the Patriots they should get
laid Rob Gronkowski is all is always
looking out for his teammates following
New England's decisive 37-22 win I love
how it was decisive we were up by eight
with four minutes to go somebody didn't
watch the game he just looked at the
final score
um 37-22 win over the bills on Sunday
the Patriots tight end wanted to give
credit to the often overlooked offensive
line he goes there's they're the ones
who should
oh they're the ones who should get laid
tonight Gronkowski said Ah that's that's
very nice of them see that wasn't bad
that wasn't bad at all
um
all right enough with the friggin
football how about the baseball
how about the baseball
you guys been watching that [ __ ] I've
been watching the uh the Royals I
haven't watched the Giants Cardinals I
saw the Cardinals had a walk-off last
night which is awesome
um
but
hang on a second where the [ __ ] did that
story go God damn it
the New York Post actually had a [ __ ]
great story about some nurse because I
don't have this all be Sports and listen
to you guys [ __ ] whining at me
for the people who don't like sports all
right nurse here's one for you for
people who aren't into sports nurse
accused of killing 38 patients she found
annoying
cops arrested a nurse in Northeast Italy
hey how you doing in connection with
deaths of as many as 38 patients who she
say she's whom she may have killed
because she found them or their
relatives annoying
wow
Daniela pogi Ali a 42 year old resident
from the town of Lugo
was taken into custody over the weekend
and booked for allegedly slaying as the
alleged sling of a 78 year old patient
Rosa Calderon who died from an injection
of potassium
calderoni had been admitted to the
hospital with a routine illness before
she died unexpectedly tests show she
died with a high amount of potassium
which can provide provoke cardiac arrest
in her bloodstream according to central
European news her death triggered an
investigation which found that 38 others
had died mysteriously
was on duty the news agency reported one
of pogi Ali's fellow nurses described
her as a cold person but always eager to
work
wow another one of Paul Ali's colleagues
said that the accused nurse was once
reported for giving powerful laxative to
patients at the end of her shift
to make work tougher for the the nurses
working after her
filed under crime comma Italy
Jesus Christ
now there's a person who never got
hugged as a child huh
what a [ __ ] so I mean
I shouldn't say that man
you know because she hasn't been
convicted of anything why did why do
they do that why do they protect the
alleged victim but not the alleged
accused
I saw something last night that was
saying that this this person out here
attacked a 68 year old woman with like a
broomstick or something outside of a
[ __ ] ATM
so then they show this guy's face
right and they just random [ __ ] name
they're like yeah they show the guy's
face on TV as mug shot and they go uh
and that is when Scott Walker allegedly
took a broomstick and smashed a 68 year
old woman over the head with it
at an ATM it's like allegedly you don't
even know if you got the right [ __ ]
guy
this guy's face is all over the [ __ ]
news
why did we have to see somebody's face
before they're convicted I don't
understand that like you know
how do you [ __ ] make a comeback from
that hey aren't you the guy who
allegedly who got accused
[ __ ]
why what is the work accuse the psalter
of a 68 year old woman like how do you
get a [ __ ] job after that
um anyway so the amount of times that
they get the wrong person don't you
think that they should maybe hold off on
showing the photo
anybody Bueller anybody anybody at all
does anybody give a [ __ ] on any level
whatsoever what the hell's the recorder
don't even tell me don't even tell me I
knocked it off
ah [ __ ]
okay good I thought for half a second I
shut it off I'm actually late today
because oh Billy boy's got a day job
Oh Billy boy's got a day job right in a
[ __ ] show that I can't wait for you
guys to see but I'm not allowed to talk
about it
until they announce it once they
announce it I'll give you a little bit
of hype on it
I think you're going to enjoy it
that's all I can [ __ ] say
um hey I want to thank everybody who
came out to the Spotlight 29 Casino
to see uh Dean Del Rey Joe bartnick and
myself we had a uh we had a wonderful
time
out there
um
I got to do more stand up though man I
really miss doing it I've been writing
this [ __ ] show
and uh kind of burning it at both ends
so uh I gotta figure that out but I'm
basically straight out writing this
thing until uh Thanksgiving
and then my schedule eases up a little
bit more I do have coming up I got some
great gigs coming up I'm doing the 20th
anniversary
of comics come home the great thing that
uh
the great benefit Foundation whatever
the hell you call it the Dennis Leary
and Cam Neely
um started 20 years ago for the Cam
Neely house which basically when um
unfortunately I think cam lost both of
his parents I know at least one of his
parents he lost to cancer and uh
you know they were in like the hospital
and that type of thing so they've made
out the Cam Neely house and so it's just
a place like during treatment where
people can rather than sitting in a
hospital can actually feel at home it's
a great thing and it's 20 years I can't
believe that because I did either Comics
come home two or three
way back in 1996.
so I don't know it's
if they were 94 95 96 that was number
three
if this is the 20th one is this the 20th
20 years or the 20th one you know what I
mean
like he played 19 years 20 Seasons like
I can't figure it out but whatever this
is either the 20th or the 20th year that
they've been doing it and um
I'm going to be up there and it's going
to be an absolute murderous row
of uh stand-up comedians on that thing
and uh one of them I can't wait to see
is going to be Steven Wright who is
arguably one of the best comedians I've
ever seen I mean he is there's no
argument there he just is I can't wait
to see him and uh
it's gonna be awesome so I got that
going on and then the next day
um I'm gonna be a Giggles Comedy Club in
Saugus
sagath on like November 9th doing a
benefit up there
and then the following week
I'm out in Florida
and on what is that
I didn't know what the [ __ ] date is
why don't I why don't I look here I'm
gonna I'm gonna
um in November I'm basically I'm going
out for Thursday Night Football when the
uh the Dolphins play the bills
and uh
I'm going to the Thursday night game
and then the next night I am in uh can
you tell I'm trying to open Windows
that's why I'm [ __ ] talking slower I
mean uh I'm at the West Palm Beach
Improv in West Palm Beach Florida
and uh doing a couple shows there
uh me Paul verzi
and uh
the next day I'm going to the Miami
Hurricane Florida Seminole game
unfortunately
it's where the Miami Hurricanes play so
I don't have to listen too much of that
[Music]
fortunately I won't have to do that the
amount of people who do that and
actually think that that's you know
like Native Americans actually used to
do that like that's actually one of
their songs rather than it was just some
horseshit that Hollywood made up
that and going
all that [ __ ]
you know what's so [ __ ] crazy is how
that stuck around for this goddamn long
the people came up with that [ __ ] do you
understand that they came up with that
[ __ ] when people didn't even know how to
act yet
at least on film or whatever like that
that was like 30 years before why I
oughta let me tell you something Shay
all of that stupid [ __ ] horrible
acting before Marlon Brando came around
and changed the game
um what's up Cleo what are you doing
come here buddy
come here
how you doing
good to see you good to see you good
decide good to see you
taking a nap
yeah that was rough wasn't it going to
the side of the house relieving yourself
and then eating a whole [ __ ] can of
dog food you must be exhausted I can
really see why you have to go there and
take another nap
huh
what do you do all day nothing why are
you always sleeping
I want an answer
nothing microphone right no Muzzle I get
nothing
all right get out of here all right okay
go on
[ __ ] love that dog
[ __ ] love that dog man
um
I will never not have a dog
you know in fact
you know this one here if we got another
dog would probably try to kill it unless
it was a baby boy from what I heard so I
don't need that drama in my house my
dog's a psycho because somebody beat the
[ __ ] out of it before I got it
um so
I'm going to keep this dog
you know and uh hopefully God willing
how old is she
five six years I want to think about
this however long she lasts and uh but
then the next round I'm getting two
I'm gonna need a blue nose and a red
nose
uh pity a couple of puppies
and that's it I'm always gonna have
[ __ ] dogs they just make your life
better they really do so anyways Hey
listen to this Oh Billy [ __ ] booze
bag is uh is seven days sober eight days
I've been drinking eight days
[ __ ] great now I'm ready to go on a
[ __ ] run that's all it takes for
those of you guys trying to knock off
the booze unless you're like a serious
[ __ ] alcoholic which fortunately I
don't suffer from that
um it takes like
five days for me is the Tipping Point if
I'm like three four days in I'm like
yeah this doesn't seem like a streak
you know like ah you know what I mean
I'm not playing tonight you know I'm
gonna sit back and [ __ ] drink a beer
you know but then once you get you know
five six days in I got a nice little run
going here
little Cal Ripken Jr Jr Jr going on here
right I want to see how long I can go
blah blah blah blah and um
I went to the uh I went to the store and
I got a bunch of those little [ __ ]
plastic tins of a bunch of Veggie [ __ ]
and I just shoved that down my pie hole
and now I got my body craving that again
I swear to God man I swear to God
um the amount of people who are [ __ ]
addicted
to sugar and salt
um has to be off the charts but I might
be doing that thing where
um I'm taking my life and superimposing
it on everybody else's you know what I
mean like well if I suffer from this
then you must suffer from it but I'm
telling you all I have to do
is wake up in the morning
and I eat just oatmeal with a [ __ ]
banana in it that fills me up
and then if I go and I get a salad
with a [ __ ] protein for lunch it's
over
then that's all it takes to kind of
break
that sugar salt sugar salt sugar salt
[ __ ] horseshit going back and forth
Pizza cookies ice cream [ __ ] burger
fries and you feel it you feel yourself
going off the rails all [ __ ] hyped up
on the salt I gotta get some sugar I
gotta [ __ ] little yeah you do a line
of [ __ ] sugar that levels you out
then you wake up the next day and both
of them are still fighting inside your
body and you wake up what do you get nah
do you get oatmeal no you grab the fruit
loops you grab the fruit loops and
you're walking out the door all hopped
up on sugar you take a handful of you
[ __ ] literally empty out all the
pretzels and just drink the salt at the
bottom of the bag just so you can get
the [ __ ] work
you know and then you just keep chasing
it
so
um I actually talked to somebody on
Twitter actually sent me a little tweet
saying that they started uh eating like
the salads and everything and and they
started craving that stuff and they
dropped like 20 pounds you know
obviously I'm no nutritional or Fitness
[ __ ] Guru but I can't tell you if you
just start eating that way it's
impossible
who likes going to the [ __ ] gym
nobody what would you rather do would
you rather spend 45 [ __ ] minutes on a
treadmill
or just sit down
and over the course of five minutes just
eat a salad
you know with some [ __ ] you know
chicken breast on there or some salmon
you know maybe just go like a total
veggie one with some beans in there
it's [ __ ] over
wouldn't you rather do that
than eating the [ __ ] you want to eat and
then jumping on a treadmill wearing out
your hips your knees and your feet
[ __ ] trying to I'm gonna run one mile
I'm gonna walk the next mile Just Eat a
[ __ ] salad
put your feet up
he just said last night when I watched
the game
I actually was sitting in a cigar bar so
I'm killing myself that way but as far
as food goes
I actually
um
what did I get I ordered this beets and
goat cheese salad which back in the day
I would be like you [ __ ] [ __ ] right
I threw that thing down my throat filled
me up I wasn't hungry and I woke up
today and uh you know Alabaster stomach
wasn't sticking out as far as I thought
it was going to be then we made me happy
I woke up this morning happy seeing that
and what did I do did I have to lift a
bunch of weights they have to run up and
down the [ __ ] Street they have to do
a bunch of burpees standing in the sand
next to some [ __ ] tanned up chick
who's never gonna [ __ ] me no I didn't I
just sat in a [ __ ] lazy boy and
fueled my body with the goddamn salad
can't recommend it enough
haven't said all that I don't know [ __ ]
about nutrition but I don't know if you
get a [ __ ] beaten goat cheese salad
with a little caramelized [ __ ]
pecans and that's absolutely delicious I
highly recommend I want you guys walking
around [ __ ]
being fat [ __ ] who wants to be a fat
[ __ ] you're there in the back you want
to be a fat [ __ ] well good for you
all right let's get uh let's get to the
uh other advertisement then I'm gonna
read some of these uh letters for the
week all right stamps.com everybody
you know that feeling you get when you
can't get things done with just the
click of your mouse
uh oh no I read that turn around you
know that feeling you get
when you can get things done with just
the click of your mouse it can't get
more convenient than that see that I
swear to God my eyes are like 20 feet
ahead of my mouth
so I went by the first can and then I
read the cant
all right let me just put it my own
words you know that feeling you get when
you got your feet up and you want you
got a bunch of stuff to do but you don't
have to get off your ass you just click
a mouse wouldn't that be great well with
stamps.com that could be yours
and now you can even get your mailing
and shipping done without ever leaving
your desk thanks to stamps.com yet
another reason to eat a salad you don't
have to get up to go to the Post Office
anymore stamps.com turns your PC or Mac
into your own personal post office that
never closes
that never has an attitude that's never
out of stamps
talk about convenient buy and this is
this this is my [ __ ] contractor I
swear to God this [ __ ] hang on a
second
all right false alarm wasn't the
contract and he's not a [ __ ]
contractor he's just a guy who comes up
to me and I owe a bunch more money hey
did you notice that the roof isn't
attached to the top of the house all
right let's get back to it here uh then
okay you buy you can buy buy and print
official US postage for any letter or
package using your computer and printer
then just hand your mail to the mailman
or drop it in the mailbox and you'll
never have to go to the post office
again
I use stamps.com to send out all of my
posters t-shirts whatever crap I'm
selling at the end of the uh the end of
my stupid show right now use my last
name Burr b-u-r-r for this special offer
no risk trial plus 110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale calculates
exact postage for letters and packages
and up to 55 free postage don't wait go
to stamps.com before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the home page and type in Burr
b-u-r-r that's stamps.com enter Burr all
right let's get to the questions for
this week
all right Japan
uh dear Billy I I'm wondering when
you're going to come to Japan and if
there's a reason you have not you have
spoken about the food many times as
being your favorite along with Italian
the countryside is beautiful so you
could you could get in a good hike uh
love you and love Nia well you know what
sir you tell me where I can go perform
over there
are there enough English-speaking
Japanese that are going to understand my
humor because I would love to go to
Tokyo I would I would love to go to
Japan
you know what I'm gonna [ __ ] make
this happen
that's it I'm going you tell me where to
go you write me back you tell me where
to go
I know that there's obviously uh we
still have bases over there
from that Whole World War II thing sorry
about that by the way you know I know we
went a little hardcore with the second
one
um so it's about time I come over there
with a little [ __ ] olive branch
and do my stupid uh you know my stupid
little [ __ ] uh tricks there little
somersault here a little punch line
there dude I would absolutely love to go
over there
um
I uh
you know obviously huge fan of the food
huge fan of the [ __ ]
architecture and everything that I've
seen over there both the Old and the new
that whole thing where you [ __ ] beat
all those Dolphins to death I don't know
about that [ __ ] but I'm sure you're not
doing it
whatever look at that alrighty we got
some comedy there I don't know [ __ ]
about your country there I said it but I
want to go I've never been to Asia I'd
love to go over there I'd love to go to
Japan see the great wall and all of that
[ __ ] I'm kidding I'm kidding I know that
that's in China
all right let's not get crazy I do this
is what I know about Asia okay
as far as I know the Japanese are
basically
the white people
of Asia in that they feel that they are
the most Superior
and over the course of the centuries
they have tried to uh
impose their will on the other people
around them is that true why would you
why would I say this about the country
that wants me to go there because I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] then you got Korea
they got North Korea you got South Korea
North Korea has that uh
one of the rarest things you'll ever see
in the world which is an out of shape
Asian guy running their country
okay
the North Koreans
to all the North Korean people are
starving and this guy is walking around
as basically a fat-faced type of [ __ ]
this is what kills me about this guy
okay if you're going to be a dictator
you know you got to feed you if you want
it to last
I guess his dad was able to starve
everybody
dude if I was a dictator I would be such
a good [ __ ] no one would try to take me
over you know I wouldn't be out there
raping and pillaging
I I would run it nice it would be all my
[ __ ] rules but I would be a nice guy
about it
when people go you know we're kind of
getting sick of that I'd be like you
know I can see that I can see that not
because I really see it just because I
don't want you guys to eventually come
and make an attempt on my life so you
know what would you like see I don't
have the backbone to be a dictator then
you got China you got a zillion [ __ ]
people
which
isn't that kind of Japan's fault because
we they kept invading them so then they
were like we're gonna have so many
[ __ ] people that no matter no matter
how many of us you kill there's going to
be another wave coming over and now look
at them
goddamn air over there was like brown
what else do I know do I know anything
positive
do I know anything positive yeah I know
something positive uh all the martial
arts come from there you got yoga came
up from [ __ ] India
uh but I know you guys had a wonderful
life until the English got there and
[ __ ] everything up which is pretty
much you know what that's the default
answer around the world yeah everything
was going great and then the English
people came there and said all right
these people here are a little bit
better than those people there a little
bit better than those people there we're
running [ __ ] and go [ __ ] yourself settle
in for the next hundred years and uh
then you'll Force us out then we're
gonna leave and you guys can continue
fighting this fight that we created that
never really existed because you're
really all the same people who should
love one another and get along
right
anyways Beatles album bill
dear Billy 100.7 FM a buddy of mine
recently got in an argument over which
has which has Beatles album
do you guys even reread what the [ __ ] he
wrote A buddy of mine recently got an
argument over which Beatles album is
probably your favorite real intellectual
stuff going on over here
he's making fun of himself uh I'm saying
I'm saying it's Let It Be or The White
Album he's he says
it's a Rubber Sole
uh
um
oh come on man how do you pick your
favorite Beatles album I mean I
definitely like their [ __ ] after uh
you know they they weren't clean cut
just singing like
you know where'd you get that baby now I
hate that [ __ ]
she loves you yeah yeah hate that [ __ ]
but when they grew out their hair and
started doing drugs I love all of that
[ __ ]
um but it's been so long since I've
listened to him I I'll have to get back
to you on that one
what's amazing about Beatles music is
they uh it's the [ __ ] that they talk
about it's still [ __ ] Timeless once
everyone say I'm looking through you
where did you go I thought I knew you
what did I know
you don't look different but things have
changed
I'm looking through you you're not the
same right that's just classic
when you're in a [ __ ] relationship
when you're young
and you think you're really into this
person in just one day
the way they answer the phone hi they
just do something you just like Ugh
he just like this isn't
you think they changed it's just you're
just learning more about the person and
you're realizing like ah this isn't this
isn't what I thought it was going to be
kind of like my house
so I like that one I also like obviously
like The White Album
I like I love Let It Be
I mean Sergeant Pepper man come on and
then you got revolver
I like all of those you know you know
what's funny is it's been so long since
those albums come out that there's a lot
of young people that think the Beatles
actually aren't they're overrated or
they stink
and um
that that's just because all that
[ __ ] music has come out since then
it's completely ripped them off
it's kind of like the Richard Pryor
thing where
how [ __ ] brilliant he was and then
after like the fifth or sixth season of
Def Jam comedy
well everybody was doing those white
people do this black people do that [ __ ]
and it was just it turned in from
Richard Pryor's specific white guy that
he was doing to just that generic uh I
gotta go do my taxes it just
um kind of took away some of the [ __ ]
that he was doing the only way to try to
because there's no way to go back in
time the only way to try to like
get yourself in that headspace look at
like a top 20 out top 100
and see what else was in the top ten and
listen to that [ __ ] versus The Beatles
album
um I guess that's the closest thing I
would say
um
I don't know who knows anyways all right
Bill I'm a female and I love your comedy
oh my God ding ding ding ding we have a
winner
well I'm going to be cliche and start by
telling you what a huge family yeah but
thank you thank you so much uh I have so
many female friends that the are they
are the epitome of what you say about
them no day off for their man or
constantly want to fix or change them
I've always been pretty mellow and from
what my husband says I am a dude trapped
in a girl's body I'm sure he might be
exaggerating a bit but it makes me smile
to know he thinks that I'm cool oh yeah
that's one of the best compliments you
can get if a guy if you're you're a
boyfriend or husband or whatever thinks
you're cool
um
and I know I'm not trying to be a
[ __ ] sexist [ __ ] here like oh you
should be oh wow oh I'm so flattered
that you [ __ ] gave me that compliment
all right don't get your tits in an
uproar here I'm just saying if
if the guy in your life actually if
you're fun to hang out with that's a
very rare thing because usually we're
trying to get away from you
um anyways she says I'm rambling now you
know for now you know for sure I'm a
woman uh she goes I spoke I saw this
quote from a movie and wanted to share
it with you uh do not try to change him
that's why so many marriages fail before
he removes the wedding veil the wife
starts to change the husband's happiness
his thoughts his friends and when she's
brainwashed him and re-mothered him
completely she wonders what happened to
the man that fascinated her the one she
fell in love with just a thought I just
thought you would enjoy that and
hopefully one of these days we'll be
able to see you live you are on our
bucket list joking thanks for your time
faithful fan no
these two emails deal with the same
situation might want to read both
together and give one answer oh that's
from uh my guy here
all right well I'll read them both
together then how to change gears with a
lady
hey Bill I've been away from home for
nine months and whenever I get a little
blue missing friends and family from
back home I just toss on your part oh
God enough with the compliments no one I
appreciate them but uh people just want
to hear the question here I was hoping
you could give me some advice I'm living
in a little house in Indonesia with a
lady who I've been best friends with for
six years
we're staying here for the next month I
hadn't seen this girl in over a year
before we met up a few days ago problem
is in the last couple of days I've
totally fallen for her oh Jesus I'm not
sure why I never felt this way about her
until now probably because you're in
[ __ ] Indonesia
you know
that's probably probably in the middle
of [ __ ] nowhere and this is your only
option you're the most beautiful girl
I've ever seen we've always made each
other laugh and always love the same
things but we never oh my God
what am I going to do here I'm just
gonna let it ring who answers their home
phone anymore
hi my name is Bert lunderquist and I'm
running for [ __ ] State cuntland
whatever the [ __ ] it is we've always
made each other laugh and always loved
the same things but we never we just
never went the boy uh Beyond a
friendship now I'm really jealous when I
see her around other guys so here's my
big idea I was thinking about asking her
out on a date
why don't I have the default ringer at
like two rings
because I never do anything to make my
life easy
one more
foreign
anyways he goes I know it's weird
because we're sharing a house
and we know each other so well but I
thought it would be better to just say
do you want to go on a date with me and
then offer to take her out for dinner
are you [ __ ] serious
and to see a band
oh my God who is on the other end that
isn't hanging up yet
I'm going to pick that up and it's going
to go seven days
I'm not picking up
oh thank Christ all right we know each
other so well but I thought it would be
better to just say do you want to go on
a date with me and then offer to take
her out for dinner and to see a band
like I would if this was someone I just
met rather than make some heavy
confession about my feelings that way
it's more of a fun thing we could try we
could try rather that's more of a fun
thing we could try rather than some big
serious decision she has to make I
thought if she was a bit reluctant I
might try saying that her friendship is
strong enough to survive one bad day
dude I think you're killing it right now
I would have never thought to do that I
would have been like oh tell her you
feel the [ __ ] that I like what you're
doing I like it way better so am I a
[ __ ] for thinking this absolutely not
is this just going to make a month
together and uh in this place awkward
and potentially ruin the trip should I
just keep my mouth shut and try to enjoy
the fact that this amazing woman is my
friend thanks in advance bill you're one
of a kind and I know that I'm trying to
ask them listen I think you should do
exactly what you want to do who knows
maybe these feelings are real maybe
they're not and you know you wouldn't be
a man if you didn't ruin a friendship
with your dick
you know everybody does it everybody
does it now I don't know how that tied
into the one above here
but uh I think you're killing it but as
far as that quote that that woman said
um
yeah I would agree I would agree with
that but I also think guys do the same
thing
guys do the same you know what you know
what also happens I think in a
relationship is you get so comfortable
if you forget to keep yourself looking
good around each other you know what I
mean
is there anything [ __ ] worse
than when you're in a relationship and
you your girlfriend is just comfortable
coming out just dressed like [ __ ] and
I'm not saying that she always has to
get [ __ ] dolled up but you know
it's the end of the night we're gonna go
watch uh
watch a [ __ ] movie you know
how long does it take to put on some
[ __ ]
cute little pajama [ __ ] half little
hurry halter top kind of thing you can't
do that it takes two seconds put your
hair in a [ __ ] ponytail think Bank
boom
you come out you make me feel like oh
yeah all right
you know I made a good choice here
you know you come out you [ __ ] yeah
you know in that goddamn fat suit
whatever the [ __ ] you know that
sweatpants and hoodie
toes all [ __ ] up I mean I just it's
just you know it's it's awful and then
the same thing goes for the guys you
know what I mean
all of a sudden you get a woman
you start eating [ __ ] mozzarella
sticks and all that [ __ ] you're coming
out there with your wife beater and your
man tits hanging out the [ __ ] side
like John Bonham towards the end of his
career that awful [ __ ] picture when
he's sitting down
this is this this is a critical thing
when you're fat standing up too
all right the last thing you need to do
is [ __ ] sit down with a wife beat
around because then it's just it's just
the rolls so they don't want to see that
either
that's this thing is a guy man you got
you got you know keep yourself in good
shape
shower and all that type of [ __ ] just
try to keep doing that throughout the
[ __ ] relationship
coming out all [ __ ] scruffy and
bleary-eyed
you know working on a pair of man tits
now women don't want to look at that
same way we don't look at them looking
all [ __ ] up so there you go
don't take the person you're with for
granted
all right look at me just telling
everybody what the [ __ ] to do all right
last one I gotta do and then I gotta I
gotta go to work
all right hey contraceptive pill bill
I'm coming to the end of my high school
life with just a few weeks ago and
there's one girl I've been waiting to
ask out for a while well don't wait any
longer uh she's hot smart funny witty
you [ __ ] get it but she's in a
different social group to me and I just
know how I sh I just don't know how I
should go about asking her out since we
spent most of the past two years taking
the same classes yet I've barely talked
to her
how would you go about talking to this
girl that you have spent a lot of time
around around you uh
you both know each other but you kept
clear of
I feel like if I don't make a move I'll
regret not doing it for the rest of my
life since she seems like she would be
an ideal girlfriend a response would be
great love the podcast go [ __ ] yourself
and get your Alabaster ass down to
Australia soon please all right dude uh
what we should do we should just go
[ __ ] ask her out because here's the
thing nothing bad will come of that
okay you won't have regret
you'll [ __ ] get over a fear which
will help you further down the line and
even if this woman says no now who knows
four or five years later you run into
her and she remembered that you liked
her you already broke down that [ __ ]
door
you might bang her
or go out with her and fall in love with
her after you 50th [ __ ] High School
Union so this is what you do for this is
what I wish I did this is what you do
right here
[ __ ] if ask her out she says no just
ask a bunch of them out
get Gino [ __ ] lay the groundwork
you're like a Salesman you're making
[ __ ] cold calls here right now for the
rest of your high school career and then
you hit every [ __ ] reunion
and you show up with a goddamn [ __ ] you
have some sunglasses and a [ __ ] white
scarf wrapped around your [ __ ] neck
like a hero and I'm telling you you'll
be [ __ ] pulling [ __ ] out of there
like uh like those [ __ ] Japanese guys
clubbing those [ __ ] Dolphins to death
it's a bad reference but you know what I
mean
that's what you should do should
absolutely 100 ask her out or whatever
just come walking up to hey how you
doing she knows your [ __ ] name
she'll say hello back
and just say listen you know I've kind
of been staring at your tits the last
couple you don't say that whatever just
[ __ ]
just ask her out just [ __ ] ask her
out nothing bad will come she has even
even if she says no she might say to her
friends you can people ask me out so and
so asked you out and one of them is
going to respect it and be like I didn't
know he had that in him maybe one of
them gets a little insecure what he
doesn't like my rock and [ __ ] hoo-ha
and next thing you know you got that
coming down the pike
okay
you got to get on the phone you got to
make your calls in the morning or you
don't get any sales at night all right
that's the [ __ ] part
that's the podcast for this week
everybody go [ __ ] yourselves
um my prediction
for the Patriots Jets uh if it's at the
Patriots I say we win
if it's at the Jets
um I don't know but I think it's going
to be a close game despite the fact that
the Jets allegedly suck and all of this
[ __ ] this is the classic game where
gamblers fall into just looking at the
numbers and looking at the records and
all of that [ __ ] and
what you have to understand is every
week what blows up your parlay there's
always that game where something
happened it makes no [ __ ] sense
all right the old Chaos Theory like
Jurassic [ __ ] park there I I the Jets
always play as tough
if we go in there and we kick the [ __ ]
out of them then they truly are a tough
[ __ ] team
um
I don't know I I don't I don't have
faith in the Patriots I just feel like
Tom Brady's been on his back the whole
even yesterday my guy was on his [ __ ]
back more than I've seen he's been on
his back more this [ __ ] season I've
seen in this goddamn career I still
think we're working that out and Ridley
went down and Mayo went down and I don't
think obviously they're going to be back
for the Thursday game I haven't looked
at the sports page yet to see how bad it
is so uh that's a huge blow to our
defense and our running game
so uh we got a lot closer to the [ __ ]
Jets all right take that with a grain